[Music]
november is a massive month for video
games
new consoles arrive with sparkly new ips
and whether you're grabbing a ps5 or
xbox series x or sticking with the
current gen options
i found a bunch of games to grab your
attention and to keep the tradition
going
more free games too three of them in
fact let's do this
let's start with the biggest game of the
month if not the entire year
cyberpunk 2077. eight
long years after the reveal of the game
it's finally time to take your place in
dystopian night city with your best pal
kianu at its core cyberpunk 2077 is a
first person rpg with plenty of action
segments
and depending on how you play it's a
first person shooter but shooting people
is not the only way to navigate the
underworld as a mercenary
your choices in-game adapt missions and
even your character's upbringing impacts
the story
there is so much to talk about and break
down here so if this floats your boat
keep an eye on the channel later this
week as my coverage starts very soon
on november 19th cyberpunk drops on pc
ps4 xbox one
and should you have the ps5 or series x
your game is playable there too with a
free upgrade
included and when the time's right a
more comprehensive update will arrive
on both platforms free upgrades are
great
but that can't be said of our next game
call of duty black ops cold war
again this is available on current gen
and next gen but to get the full
experience on ps5 or series
x you have to pay an additional fee but
i'm not here to judge just wanted to let
you know
black ops cold war continues the first
person shooter shenanigans of the call
of duty series
and like always the gun play feels ultra
slick
and incredibly satisfying nothing comes
close to this
as the name suggests cold war is set
around the real life cold war
in which we follow cia officer russell
adler
as they pursue a soviet spy cold war
sticks to the original black ops much
more closely and doesn't jump forward
like it did in black ops 3.
was that 2065 that one set in anyway
everything is far more in keeping with
the correct time period
black ops cold war brings back the
zombie mode many people
absolutely adore this time with a new
storyline which we thought was concluded
in black ops 4.
there's a new mode called zombie
onslaught to play this year and that's
exclusive to playstation
for an entire year wow anyway call of
duty black ops cold war drops on
playstation xbox and pc
on november 13th
[Music]
another action rpg now in the shape of
assassin's creed valhalla
playing as avor the viking as they
travel into england to settle there by
any means necessary 2019 was the first
year since the series began
in 2007 that there was not an ascreed
game
that extra year in between entries has
reinvigored the audience and now many of
us want to jump back in again
over the years the action adventure game
has fully embraced rpg elements
and that continues here with loot drops
and the ever
increasing numbers on all our loot
that's the core loop here
england is a country divided and avor
uses this to build relationships with
rulers
of different kingdoms there each
reacting in different ways
i've played about eight hours and if
you've played and enjoyed origins or
odyssey you'll be very happy once again
with but tons of activities including
the gradual upgrade of your settlement
in which you can have viking insult
battles whilst drinking like an
alcoholic
happy days with hunting fishing viking
raiding parties and so much
customization too
this game could last you weeks if not
months
assassin's creed valhalla arrives on
november 10th on ps4 pc and xbox one
with free upgrades to ps5 and xbox
series x
spider-man returns in november but this
time it's not all about peter parker
miles morales one of the youngest and
most loved versions of the web slinger
gets his own game well sort of
spider-man mas morales is coming to ps4
on ps5 on november the 12th
i say kinder because miles is not quite
getting a full length outing
and yet it's far more than a simple dlc
the average play time is said to be
around 15 hours
if you played the dlc from the 2018 game
you'll know that peter has been training
miles
and it looks like now is the time for
him to venture out alone
the game can be purchased alone or for
the full experience there is an
ultimate edition which slams together
the remaster of the 2018
game complete with all the dlc and a
shiny new peter parker
who looks less like andrew garfield now
and more like tom holland
definitely a coincidence right and just
in case you're thinking this is a reskin
featuring miles
then take this to note miles has his own
abilities his own story arc
and his own cat spider cat confirmed
count me in
okay now i know that everyone can't
afford every game that comes out
so i found three free games you can grab
first up on november 25th
ps4 and ps5 players can get their hands
on vigor
and if you're on xbox or switch yes
switch i said twitch
you can grab it right now so what the
heck is vigor vigor is an end of the
world survival game
based in norway you may think it looks a
lot like dayz
and that's because it's made by the same
people the premise is quite simple
upgrade your shelter to do this we need
to loot and shoot against other players
grabbing precious items and escaping
back home the kicker is
if we die we lose everything we
currently have on our character
this is a risk reward to the max over
time our shelter updates in real time
which is also our hub we'll come back
here to craft weapons and bullets and
meds and anything we want to take
into our next deadly encounter with
multiple maps with weather and terrain
changes to mix up the difficulty
and there's a random airdrop possibility
which has the best loot possible but it
also attracts
all the players in the lobby it's going
to be a bloodbath i did say it was risk
reward
maybe it's time to team up with friends
ones you can trust anyway
how about another free game okay here's
another one
sadly this one is only available in the
n a region right now
although there is talk by the end of
november it will appear elsewhere in the
world
operation 7 showdown is a free-to-play
third-person shooter
it follows up on the pc game named
operation seven but now it's on console
as you can see it looks a great deal
like pubg but if i'm honest it lacks all
the finesse the game modes are small
sided deathmatch style games with
emphasis on attacking and defending
points on the map there are vehicles
dotted about too which adds a little
variety to the strategy in team play
i've played this and maybe it was my
connection from across the world
but i don't think i can recommend it
maybe it will improve over time
i'd personally suggest trying rogue
company which dropped last month
and that's also completely free it's a
far better third person team shooter
with much more controlled mechanics
okay let's try again on the free-to-play
front this is
bless unleashed an open world mmo which
is available right now on ps4 and xbox
one
if you've heard of bless online you'll
know where the origins of this title
come from but this version
is like a reboot using a free-to-play
model we create a character then take
them into this fantasy world to explore
and complete errands and missions
bless is a class-based mmo with the
berserker class given access to
two-handed weapons the mage is magic
focused the ranger is all about
projectiles from distance
the priest is suited to healing others
and the crusader resembles like a tank
with a sword and shield option
with a mix of pve and pvp there's a ton
of things to lose your time to
there's a 15 on 15 pvp battle mode
and there's a smaller sided three on
three micro arena too
but if you prefer teaming against the ai
rather than other people
then look out for world bosses you can
stumble across in game in the open world
and like all good mmos there are
dungeons to fight through
so if you're looking for a new mmorpg
then check out bless online which
released on ps4
three days before i made this video
our next game is a ps5 exclusive new ip
destruction all stars dropping on
november 12th
i need to interrupt myself right now
because destruction all stars
was just delayed the moment i uploaded
this video to youtube
rip of the dream it's not all doom and
gloom though as the new release date is
february 2021
and it will be free on ps plus to make
up for this letdown
i'm gutted right now but i'm happy more
people will play this on ps plus next
year
so oh well let's move on what's next
next we have godfall the first game
officially announced as a ps5 title but
you can also grab it on pc2
godfall is referred to as an action
role-playing game with looter slasher
elements
and i gotta admit that fits pretty well
just look at the combat
it's hectic to say the least the world
of godfall is split into realms of earth
air water fire and spirit playing as one
of the last of the night's order
in this apocalyptic shape world we
harness those elements
to evolve our warriors the weapons range
from dual blades to greatswords to
warhammers
and is always focused on achieving the
next tier of loot
there's something addictive about
numbers going up on all our gear
god4 supports three-player co-op with
drop-in dropout functions to keep the
game moving forward
without breaking the action which is
nice to hear god fall drops on november
12th or 19th
depending on when the ps5 releases for
you
and finally the long-awaited return of
demon souls is officially here
the remake of the sublime original hits
ps5 on release day
demon souls is where the dark souls
series began and coined the memes about
multiple deaths in gaming
demon souls on ps3 was hard so damn hard
and i never actually played it due to
the fear of failure
the gameplay is centered around perfect
knowledge of fights and an emphasis
on timing attacks and defense the game
is slow and methodical and at any moment
a slip in
can lead to yet another death this is
totally a game for the hardcore
and there's also a world invasion
mechanic making it possible to do
exactly that
invade other players and either help
them or hinder them
i know what you're going to do i wonder
how many new dual shot controllers are
gonna be smashed due to demon souls
we shall see so there we have it 10
games that you may want to play
any take your fancy we didn't get time
to talk about sac boys big adventure or
dirt five and there's there's so many
more
november 2020 it's a great time to be a
gamer
i'm adam from playstation grenade it's
been a pleasure i'll see you next time